tell me about this suit though well you
know I felt like it was a good pop of
color it matches the Jumanji logo it's a
very simple choice plus I didn't fade DJ
to be in such a elaborate jacket so I'm
glad I grounded it with some you know
company so DJ went all-in and get the
pink jacket on the other night he's
really gone for on to a different level
with his fashion sense did you talk to
him did you talk to him I didn't have a
conversation he did it on his own and it
looks amazing
yeah we're in the world as Priyanka why
isn't she here with you tonight she's in
India right now she's shooting a movie
there although she's jealous because she
loves Jumanji she loved the last one and
she really wanted to be here but she's
got work how do you do that balancing
her being on the other side of the world
she she's done soon with this movie and
then she'll be back for a while but I
thought we know we've also been on tour
since we saw your last basically yeah so
it's been almost four and a half months
on the road and it's been you know
interesting but we we have an incredibly
beautiful balance in our lives and kind
of an understanding of our priorities
you know that's the most important thing
will you take a break now you've been
making movies and touring and doing all
this will you guys just lay low for a
second or no see I don't know I got the
voice too so I got the voice we started
shooting the blind auditions already and
we've got the
battle rounds coming up in January so
new we finish the tour I go to that and
we go back on tour a lot but it's all in
good fun
I think I'm most excited about as the
holidays getting meant to relax and for
people to see this movie eventually
thought you might need some help
where is Bethany she's right here she
says oh my god like I'm a total horse
hey it seems like two is just setting up
number three you know I haven't actually
seen it yet tonight have you not seen
them cuz I've been on the road I haven't
had a night up but I'm gonna see it
tonight for the first time and I'm so
excited so you're telling me that then
there is another one put coming probably
I feel it okay
I hope they call me back okay we're
doing this thing called eat eat up where
someone asks a question and then you
answer and then you get to ask the next
question so the last question left
biased one of your co-stars was what is
your favorite type of birthday cake I'm
actually not a cake guy like pumpkin pie
okay you lay out the question for the
next person okay here's my question if
you were a bird what kind of bird would
you be options
[Music]